If you are in some kind of room,
I encourage you now to make a small experiment.
Look around the room and see if there is anything in it,
which is made of wood or paper or fabric,
and was in the room for a while,
so I hope it's at room temperature.
And then found something else that was made of metal,
who has been in the room for some time
and does not have its own energy source,
so do not use your computer.
It has to be something that passively stays in your room for some time,
not too hard to find one.
Touch both of them.
And you'll see that even though they both stayed for a while in this room,
the metal will be much colder.
You will feel that the metal is colder.
And this is a little confusing,
because they both stayed in this room for some time,
so both must have room temperature.
Let's do that a bit more accurately.
Let's say the room temperature is 70 degrees Fahrenheit.
And the key reason to be colder is,
that the room temperature is lower than your body temperature.
Your body temperature will be approximately 37 degrees Celsius.
Let me write this - it's body temperature.
And the surface temperature of your skin may be slightly different than that,
but let's just assume it's about 37 degrees Celsius.
And this metal, this metal surface is not actually colder.
In fact, there is no lower average kinetic energy than the wood surface.
They both stayed in this room for a while,
both have a temperature of 22 degrees Celsius.
What happened?
Why your skin and your brain
does the metal feel colder?
And the simple answer is that he is better
in removing heat from you.
Why is it better to take heat from me?
Let's just imagine, let's say,
that this is the atoms on the surface of my skin.
These are the atoms on the surface of my skin,
the lower part of my skin, say my hand
touching one surface here.
This is my thumb here
and touch the surface.
And there will be average kinetic energy,
which will be in terms of my body temperature
37 degrees Celsius.
These things will bounce around or vibrate around.
And perhaps the covalent bonds between carbon atoms
and the other atoms of my skin
do not allow them to free themselves completely,
but they will tremble, will bounce around.
And even push each other
and this can be done by electrostatic forces.
But they will have some average kinetic energy.
And let's say my hand touches both surfaces at the same time.
I have this wood surface, I will do this in yellow.
I have the wooden surface here.
This is a tree.
And I have this metal surface - I'll do that in white.
I have the metal surface here.
And this metal surface - we've already talked about it -
it will feel colder.
Let me draw the rest of my hand.
The rest of my hand - you get the idea.
What is going on here?
Let's think about it at a microscopic level.
First, the surface of the tree will be uneven.
You will have atoms here, but you will have gaps,
there will be air here.
Let's roll a little down.
It will be like this -
you will have gaps.
And there will be internal gaps, that's right.
This will be the tree,
while the metal is much thicker.
And the surface is much smoother.
The metal - let's make the metal in this white color -
the atoms of the metal are much more crowded.
It is much thicker, the surface is smoother,
there are no internal air pockets,
there will be no air pockets in it.
What will happen?
We always said, you'll have a heat transfer
from the higher temperature system,
or something with a higher temperature,
to the lower temperature.
They will already have some kinetic energy,
these things will have average kinetic energy,
which corresponds to 22 degrees Celsius.
Let's draw some of these arrows.
So it is here too - they will have it
the same average kinetic energy.
These things are pushed around, pushing one another
with electrostatic forces.
I hope this gives you an idea of ​​what's going on.
But my hand is warmer,
my arm has a higher average kinetic energy.
The atoms and molecules of my hand
will hit the atoms and molecules of the tree
and will transfer kinetic energy.
But we realize that the tree makes weaker contact.
Because first, the surface of the tree is not smooth,
that is, it touches less.
This here can simply crash with another air particle,
will not crash into a piece of wood.
But some of the particles of the tree will begin
to take kinetic energy from me.
And I will feel this as a chill.
Maybe it takes a little kinetic energy,
it's getting stuck in that.
The kinetic energy is transferred down.
But it will be rolled down much slower,
than it will happen in the metal.
Because first, I do not have so much surface contact
between my hand and the tree,
due to all these gaps.
And in the tree I also have air pockets.
And overall, the tree is not so tight.
There will be less collisions and it will take longer
this energy is transferred from my hand.
And the metal, on the other hand,
as soon as this atom crashes into this one,
it will crash into this, it will crash into this one,
this will crash into this one.
And this kinetic energy will very quickly be dragged down the metal.
He can take more heat than me.
This molecule here will get
some kinetic energy from a molecule in my hand.
But then she'll hit her neighbor
and will transfer this kinetic energy.
He will lose his kinetic energy quite quickly
and is ready to be struck again by another molecule from my hand,
and take more kinetic energy.
I will take heat from me faster.
You have a faster energy transfer,
than you have with the tree.
And from the point of view of your body,
that this heat is taken away faster than you,
although both surfaces are actually of the same temperature,
your body perceives this here as colder.